Welcome to Community Group Certification training.
This is our first week in a seven week series,
and this is a practical and passionate and philosophical view
of community group ministry.
And so we'll start off with a vision casting opportunity.
And I wanna start off with what I call the Lego principle.
How many of you have played with Legos as a child?
And how many of you have got kids now,
or grandkids that build all kinds of things?
My granddaughters love Legos and never saw that coming.
But look at these incredible Lego projects behind me.
It's amazing what God can do with, uh, our designs,
the way he created us in his image,
if we'll work together and if we'll put our minds to it.
There's amazing things that we can do even with toys. If you think about it,
individual Legos are like people in our church. Like people,
Legos come in all different sizes and shapes and colors,
and each Lego has a certain amount of snap-on points. Now,
every person who attends a community group also has a certain amount of
snap-on points.
And snap-on points represent time and energy and resources that
every individual has to give to their church.
Each person has a limited amount of time and resources and energy to give to the
church. And so, uh,
the longer an individual is involved in the church or in a community group,
the more and more snap-on points are taken up.
So a longtime church member may have a few or even zero snap-on points left
to give.
So what happens when a prospect joins a community group and needs
to snap on others in the class? Well,
if the community group members have no snap-on points to give away,
this lonely soul has no one left to attach to.
So if this new guest or prospect or this new community group member
remains lonely and detached and disconnected,
they're gonna become disgruntled and they may quit the class or quit the church
altogether.
They could believe and communicate to everyone who they see after having left
the class or the church,
that the community group or the church is unfriendly or even worse
uncaring. For this reason,
I wanna offer a practical and passionate approach to community group ministry.
And I want us to remember our five purposes of a community group. Number one,
reaching people for Christ. That's what we'll be talking about tonight. Also,
teaching people the Bible ministering to one another in this,
in the community group,
serving the Lord together as a community group and integrating the mission and
vision of our church as a community group.
These purposes work and they are good. We're good at ministering to one another.
It's very intuitive because the group loves to get together and build
relationships and share life together.
We're also very good at teaching people the Bible. Uh,
a community group that doesn't teach. The Bible doesn't get it. We
Are here to teach the Bible. This is key.
But the first purpose reaching people for Christ is often neglected.
It's not as intuitive. But listen to this.
Did you know that for every three unbelieving people enrolled in your community
group one will come to faith in Christ within a year? Did you hear that?
One out of three will come to Christ within a year?
Think about that for a moment. We wanna see people led to Jesus.
We wanna see people baptized doing his church.
We wanna see our church reach more people and grow in its influence and its
effective ministry. So the only way, one of the only ways,
the best way perhaps for us to do that is to increase the number of people in
our church. That means our community groups reaching people for Christ.
It works. It works 75 years ago and it works today.
Let me tell you a secret.
We have right at 60 adult community groups in our church right now.
Some meet on Sundays, some on Sunday nights, some on Mondays,
some on Wednesdays, even some on Fridays.
But what what I need for you to understand is that we still have room for
more community groups. Maybe not on Sunday morning at nine or 10 30,
but at other times we must start new community groups.
It's true that community groups grow faster than those that have been meeting
for a long time. And if we start 10 new adult classes in 2024,
every one of them will grow and new classes grow fastest. It's a fact.
Now, we might not be able to start 10 new community groups in 2024,
but we could start with one.
And each of us leaders can do everything we can to promote the reality
that reaching people for Christ means multiplying our community groups.
We must grasp the vision of the Great commission.
Matthew 28, 18, 19 and 20 talks about authority.
The issue of authority is completely settled. Jesus said,
all authority has been given unto me. Therefore,
go and make disciples of all nations. We do include teaching,
but if we don't reach them for Christ,
there's no one to teach to observe everything that Jesus has commanded us.
It's a proven fact that starting new groups is paramount in church growth
strategy.
New groups involve more people and they have more relationships and they do more
ministry. So here is a simple proven formula.
New groups equals new people, equals new growth. It's simple.
It's not hard to figure out, and it it follows the commands of God.
Listen to what Jesus said in John three 16.
Whoever believes in him should not perish, but have eternal life.
One Timothy one, uh, two four, Paul said to Timothy about God, our savior,
he said,
he who desires all people to be saved and common to the knowledge of the truth.
And then there's two Peter three, nine.
The Lord is not slow to fulfill his promise as some count slowness,
but is patient
Towards you. Not wishing that any should perish,
but that all should come to repentance.
So we must constantly remind ourselves that the church and the
community group is not just for us. In fact,
a more evangelistic or missional perspective is that we are here for those who
are not here yet,
it's God's will for Christians to reproduce themselves and to make disciples of
others. Disciples who make disciples,
who make disciples and it's God's will for churches to reproduce themselves and
start new mission churches. That's the vision of our church.
It's consistent to believe then that God intends for community groups to
reproduce themselves. Also,
community groups should experience the genuine meaning and
fulfillment in the fact that they have intentionally prayed and worked
to start and multiply a new group. Why multiply?
Because leaders will need to help their class members adopt this a philosophy
and understand it's a purpose of a community group,
not just to grow closer together in relationship,
but to grow closer together so that they can launch new believers and,
and not new believers, but new members into new groups and continue to multiply.
We will adopt that philosophy and we will adopt the purpose of multiplying new
classes. Now,
those who don't understand will resist this concept. In fact,
they don't know whether it will or will not make a difference.
And typically they can resurrect a story about a new community group that
failed,
but clearly it will make a difference because it provides opportunities
for others to become active and exercise the spiritual gifts that God has given
them.
If a community group teacher must ask himself whose gifts and
abilities are lying dormant in this community group, then uh,
it's poor stewardship of God's gifting the, uh,
kingdom minded community group Bible teacher must discover these dormant gifts
and then put them into service within the body of Christ,
specifically within their community group,
so that those gifts can be exercised and grow and become fruitful.
God did not intend for his children to waste the gifts that he has entrusted to
them,
and he certainly didn't intend for the church to deny people opportunities to
exercise God's giftedness.
I want to conclude our time together by looking at the threat of losing
evangelistic influence.
This is a passage in Matthew five 13 and 14 where Jesus is talking
about how it is possible for, uh,
his followers to lose their evangelistic influence. Now,
we can all agree these are turbulent times and uh, as,
as badly as any other time people need Jesus.
But as we navigate these turbulent
Times,
a community group leaders must refocus their intention on captivating
the power of Jesus. And Jesus has said, uh,
I am with you always and that I will empower you.
You will be my witnesses in Jerusalem, Judea,
and the Holy Spirit will come upon you. But then I want you to take a,
a real quick look at these two metaphors that Jesus gave us in Matthew five 13
and 14. In Jesus', most famous teaching, he warned,
you are the salt of the earth.
But if salt lost its taste, how shall its saltiness be restored?
It's no longer good for anything but that he thrown out and trample under
people's feet.
So Jesus is saying that tasteless salt is,
it's a risk of losing our distinctiveness as the Christians that God is
creating us to be. Jesus taught the threat of becoming tasteless.
Salt is real. And when we conform to the world's standards,
when we compromise our core values,
when we find ourselves comfortable with our surroundings,
we lose our distinctiveness and we lose our opportunity to make a real impact in
the world.
It weakens our ability to spread the transformative message of the gospel
of Jesus Christ. You know, salt in ancient times was a preservative,
but it was also a flavor enhancer.
And Christians like salt are called to preserve and called to enrich
the moral fabric of society and reflect the glory of Jesus to people who need
him. The second metaphor that Jesus used was hidden candles.
And this is the danger of diminished visibility.
Jesus continues in verse 14 and 15, and he said, you are the light of the world.
A city on a hill cannot be hidden,
nor do people light a lamp and put it under a basket, but on a stand,
and it gives light to all the house. You see, light serves as a guide.
It dispels the darkness and it reveals truth.
And Jesus compares Christians to candles.
They're meant to shine brightly in a world and a world that's shrouded by
spiritual darkness.
The danger of hidden candles lurks as community group groups
give into contentment or apathy or complacency and don't
realize what God is calling them and creating them to do.
When the light of Christ is within a believer,
when it dems the impact of our evangelistic opportunities diminish,
we must rekindle the flames of passion and courage.
We must position ourselves as beacons of hope and truth,
unafraid to shine the light for all to see.
May we continue to shine as beacons of light,
creating new community groups that will shine ever brighter,
impacting the lives and beaming light ever brighter on our spiritual journey.
May we serve Jesus with heartfelt gratitude and a vision for an even
brighter future.